[MUSIC]
There's a large amount of working from
home goes on,
at all levels of employment, from the call
center people that we were dealing with,
who are reasonably lowly paid and not
terribly skilled.
Up through programmers regularly work from
home,
database administrators reg, regularly
work from home.
Several of the most prominent Valley firms
encourage managers to work from home.
And this is the first evidence we have
about the efficacy of that.
[MUSIC]
What we found was that working from home
turned out to be a win-win.
The employees, the employees were happier
because they
weren't having to commute an hour and a
half a day.
The firm saved on real estate.
And the employees worked more and worked
more efficiently.
More because saving time on commuting,
they didn't have to
take time off to go to the dentist or take
the kids to the doctor.
And more effectively because working at
home was quieter than working in a noisy
call center.
So they didn't have to ask clients to
repeat themselves.
The people who were working at home worked
about 9% longer, a lot,
9% bigger share of their assigned eight
hour shift.
They took smaller breaks and fewer hour,
time off.
And they also were about 4% more
effective.
So 13% gain and output.
Then once people were allowed to decide
where they wanted to
work it jumped to 22%.
And a large part of this was that some
people found though they
thought they wanted to work at home, they
were just too lonely.
They wanted to get back to the office.
And so the people who chose to work from
home, knowing what they were getting into,
were even more effective and more
productive.
[MUSIC]
Working from home works really well for
some people, that, we've proven that.
In some people, in some companies, some
jobs.
I don't think it necessarily would work
well for
all people in all jobs at all times.
There's, the, the manager has to
understand the tasks that
are involved in the job, understand the
mechanisms that can be used to control and
motivate the employees who are working at
home.
And has to understand the, the social
implications.
A lot of our employees at Sea Trip became
lonely and
didn't want to work at home any more.
You'd worry that in another context,
people who were not in frequent contact
with one another would be less innovative.
You really just have to think through the
individual situation.
And maybe run your own experiment.
What the CEO, Marissa Mayer at Yahoo's
doing, isn't really much
about working from home or not working
from home, it's about not working.
Yahoo has been a company in big trouble,
in, in, a death spiral for several years.
And as I learned while being interviewed
repeatedly about her,
her outlawing working from home.
The company just wasn't working and people
weren't working.
People who were nominally working from
home were, in fact,
setting up their own companies on, on
Yahoo's time.
And the culture at Yahoo had become really
dysfunctional.
And what I see her doing is trying to
change the culture.
To save the company and, and that's, this
is one element of it.
She's got, you've got to do that face to
face.
You can't do that over, over email.
[MUSIC]
If workers want to, want to experiment
with working from home
one of the things to do is to approach the
boss with, with some data.
And the old data is a start but
this new data is, is gold standard stuff.
How much you wanna rely on our work rather
than
other stuff may depend a lot on how much
your job looks like the call centers.
Where the bosses can be sure that you'll
be motivated to,
to work once you're home and
not to sit around in your bathrobe and
play Angry Birds.
[MUSIC]
Now this is an area where there's been
really no scientific research at all.
There's surveys and there's case studies.
But you never have any idea what's really
cause and effect in a situation like that.
Whereas here, because of the
randomization, we could pretty well ensure
that that the changes we saw were driven
by the changes in the management practice.
And any time you find management, good
evidence that management really works, for
somebody who's spent 40 plus years
teaching management, that's,
that's a good day.
[MUSIC]